Comic book stories are no longer just Marvel
and DC's domain.
Writer Mark Millar's series "Jupiter's Legacy"
got the Netflix treatment in 2021 with an
8-episode season.
After years of work spent bringing it to life,
it was cancelled after only one month.
Here's the untold truth of the short-lived
show.
When Stan Lee gives you comic advice, you
take it.
Lee co-created Marvel's most iconic characters,
but he never owned his own Marvel work — which
led to a much lower cut of the profits from
Lee's characters than he deserved.
Lee even sued Marvel in 2002, dismayed with
the meager cut he received from the first
"Spider-Man" movie.
Mark Millar worked for Marvel when Lee encouraged
him to break from the company to create his
own content.
Wanting to help Millar avoid the same mistakes
he made, Lee coached the budding comic book
writer to write for himself instead of a large
company.
Speaking with Business Insider in 2015, Millar
revealed some of the helpful advice that Lee
had given him:
"He said, 'Financially, now it's so much better
for you guys than it ever was for me.
You could own the rights to your own movies
and books.
You could license this stuff to people, like
toys.
If I had the opportunity you've had, I'd have
killed for it.'"
"And with great power, comes—"
"Great responsibility."
"No.
Well, yeah."
Given the success that Millar has had as a
creator in comics, movies, and TV, it seems
like Stan Lee's advice was worth listening
to.
It's not often that a major studio buys an
entire company, but that's precisely what
happened with Mark Millar's Millarworld company
in 2017 when Netflix bought the whole shebang
for around $40 million.
Of course, the acquisition includes all of
Millar's comic works from the company beyond
"Jupiter's Legacy" — including properties
like "Kick-Ass," "Kingsman," and "The Magic
Order," Netflix's first comic book series,
which was released after the company purchased
Millarworld.
Given the prior success of Millar's many works
on screen, the purchase doesn't seem to have
been a huge risk for the streaming giant.
Given that the acquisition happened in 2017,
what took so long for the series to end up
on Netflix?
Millar told The Hollywood Reporter in April
2021 that he had spent time focusing more
on the series' quality, rather than worrying
about how quickly he could get it out, saying,
"You can do it fast, or you can do it brilliant.
That's my philosophy."
Still heeding Stan Lee's advice, Millar made
sure that he would remain president of Millarworld
even after the acquisition.
In a May 2021 press release about "Jupiter's
Legacy," Millar noted,
"When my wife, Lucy, and I sold Millarworld
to Netflix in 2017, our first priority was
'Jupiter's Legacy.'
We had flirted with the idea of a movie, but
Netflix afforded us the chance to make this
adaptation as big and deep as it needed to
be."
Millar first conceptualized the "Jupiter's
Legacy" series in 2008, but the first issue
wasn't published until 2013.
Millar handled the words while Frank Quitely
handed the series' illustrations, and Pete
Doherty took on the lettering.
As Millar told The Hollywood Reporter, the
"Jupiter's Legacy" comics are the longest-running
series Millar has ever published, spanning
over 20 issues.
The Netflix series covers five issues over
a single eight-episode season.
Compared to comic book universes like DC and
Marvel, eight years between publishing the
first comic and landing a massive Netflix
deal for the series isn't exactly a long wait
time.
Some comics take decades to get adapted for
the screen, so going from the page to a full-scale
film production in that short a time is far
from ordinary.
Of course, it helps that "Jupiter's Legacy"
is far from Mark Millar's first foray into
Hollywood.
With his resume, it was only a matter of time
before "Jupiter's Legacy" was added to his
filmography.
Few directors have had more success with superhero
movies than James Gunn.
The director brought "Guardians of the Galaxy"
to the big screen for the first time, establishing
a new beloved franchise in the Marvel film
canon.
He also picked up the pieces from DC's "Suicide
Squad" property with a reimagined follow-up,
2021's "The Suicide Squad."
So when Gunn gave Millar advice about what
he should do with his "Jupiter's Legacy" property,
Millar had good reason to listen.
While "Jupiter's Legacy" was initially conceived
as a trilogy film series in 2015 with Lorenzo
di Bonaventura in a production role, Millar
discarded the plan with a push from Gunn.
During an interview with Den of Geek, Mark
Millar revealed that Gunn told him that the
comics "could never work as a movie."
Much of Millar's success comes from listening
to those who have come before him, and he
proved more than willing to listen to this
advice.
As Millar told Den of Geek, quote, "the smartest
guy in the world is James Gunn."
Most TV shows with heavy backstory take an
episode or two to lay out the origin story
when delving into the characters' histories
— but Mark Millar had other ideas with "Jupiter's
Legacy."
Instead of spending a minute (or 40) delving
into the history of the first superheroes
in the "Jupiter's Legacy" canon, we get to
watch the historical origins of the Union
of Justice members be revealed throughout
the series, one piece at a time.
Jumping between past and present, the series
dips into its characters' Great Depression
backstory, covering their respective histories
when it's relevant to do so.
So, what exactly influenced Millar to take
this route?
During an interview with The Wrap, he revealed
that "The Godfather Part II" provided the
inspiration for the series' woven time jumps.
According to Millar, the idea was pitched
by Steven DeKnight, the original showrunner
for "Jupiter's Legacy."
In the same way that Michael Corleone and
his father Vito's stories play out at the
same time, decades apart, so too do the stories
of Sheldon and Brandon in "Jupiter's Legacy."
Millar explained,
"The 'Godfather II' structure shows the father
and the son at the same age.
And that's the same thing that's been done
here, to show the young characters and the
old characters at the same age and essentially
making the same mistakes."
"Jupiter's Legacy" has an infinite number
of comic book parallels.
However, the deepest connection that Skyfox
actor Matt Lanter sees might not be what you'd
expect.
The actor noted the similarities between his
"Jupiter's Legacy" character and his role
as Anakin Skywalker on "Star Wars: The Clone
Wars" — and the outdated rules of conduct
that plague the heroes of both worlds.
Lanter chatted with Looper during an exclusive
interview, where he compared the rigid nature
of the Jedi Council to the strict rules of
the Union in "Jupiter's Legacy."
He said,
"The Jedi Council seems antiquated and just
doesn't apply in every situation anymore.
And the Jedi Council is so black and white
[in its thinking].
I think Anakin realized that things aren't
black and white.
In fact, there are shades of gray, and that's
exactly what's going on in 'Jupiter's Legacy.'"
In both cases, these unwavering rules lead
to the downfall of an otherwise relatively
moral hero.
The fickle beast that is Mother Nature something
that almost every series or movie deals with
at some point during shooting.
When the weather decides to do something unexpected,
production has two options: Roll with it,
or halt production.
Luckily for "Jupiter's Legacy," when the skies
opened for a dramatic snowstorm, the weather
only enhanced the scene's otherworldly quality.
During an exclusive interview with Looper,
cinematographer Nicole Hirsch Whittaker — director
of photography for several episodes of "Jupiter's
Legacy" — revealed the perils of filming
in an unpredictable Canadian climate.
In one episode in particular, the series'
seventh, the weather wasn't cooperating, leading
to heavy — and unscripted — snowfall.
While they were shooting a scene in the woods
over the course of a few days, Whittaker explained,
"We all went back to our hotels and woke up
in the morning, and there was two feet of
snow on the ground, which is very Canadian.
We were like, 'Oh my gosh, there's a snowstorm.'
So basically we got to set, everybody talked
about it and decided this is an island that's
alive, so let's embrace it.
[...] So they started writing, and within
an hour we had a new script."
Luckily for fans, the surprise snow lends
an incredibly realistic backdrop to the scene.
Given that the characters head to the island
to claim their superpowers, they deal with
a whole host of challenges — now including
unpredictable weather.
The first flashback we get in "Jupiter's Legacy"
kicks off the events of The Great Depression
as the stock market crashes.
While it's undoubtedly a fascinating point
in American history, it's a unique time period
to place the origin story of a group of slowly
aging superheroes.
However, the period makes sense given the
year in which Millar began writing the comics.
2008 marked a steady economic decline, leading
to a financial crisis of the likes the world
hadn't seen since the Great Depression.
"'The Death of Capitalism' — that is one
hell of a headline."
Millar told The Hollywood Reporter in April
2021,
"When I sat down to do this — it was three
years before I actually [wrote] it, during
the financial crash in 2008 — I said, 'I'm
not going to do this unless I can make it
the greatest superhero story of all time.'"
Setting the superheroes' origin stories in
the late '20s with Great Depression ties certainly
set the story apart from many of its counterparts.
The choice roots the series in a reality that
almost everyone can relate to, and offers
a unique vantage point for the story to cover.
As we've seen with the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and DC Extended Universe, there's no shortage
of stories waiting to be told when film studios
decide to tap into comics characters' legacies.
With plenty of source material waiting to
be mined, "Jupiter's Legacy" seemed poised
to enjoy a multiple-season run on Netflix
— but any hopes fans may have had for follow-up
installments were dashed in early June of
2021, when Millar announced that the cast
had been released from its contracts.
Although Millar indicated that he hadn't quite
given up hope for more "Jupiter's Legacy"
onscreen at some point, in the short term,
Netflix's decision means the show has been
canceled.
On the bright side, this frees Millar up for
other projects, like the upcoming "Supercrooks"
series he's set to debut for the platform.
It's still a bitter pill to swallow for viewers
who came to love the "Jupiter's Legacy" characters
throughout the show, but they can always turn
to the comics for more stories — the latest
chapter of the saga, "Jupiter's Legacy: Requiem,"
was already set to begin arriving in comic
shops when the show's cancellation was announced.
So, where exactly does Millarworld, and more
specifically, "Jupiter's Legacy," fall in
the comic book landscape?
If you ask Matt Lanter, he'll tell you that
it's the future of comics — and deserves
a spot at the top with DC and Marvel.
In fact, we did ask Matt Lanter during a Looper
exclusive interview.
He said,
"I think five years from now, everyone's going
to know that it's Millarworld, it's DC, and
it's Marvel.
So get to know these characters now, be the
first on the train and have fun with it, man."
That's a pretty big claim, but it's not without
merit.
Even though the series isn't moving forward
on Netflix, the show still made a huge impression
on viewers with a rock-solid debut on the
streamer, coming in as the number one program
on the platform upon its release.
Additionally, as far as box office is concerned,
Millar's 2010 film "Kick-Ass" brought in over
$96 million worldwide, and "Kingsman: The
Secret Service" raked in over $414 million.
Those are numbers that are in the range of
or even surpass some early MCU projects like
"Captain America: The First Avenger," which
brought in over $370 million.
In other words, just because "Jupiter's Legacy"
may be over on Netflix, that doesn't mean
it's not still the start of something big.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.